real rusty didn't eNOS come back the
other night like I told you I put the
two shots that make the shot from the
tunnel Oh LeBron that thing was in the
ear so long it should have had a movie
on it he is in full rhythm right now
backing down Lowry heat chest still
sizzling LeBron James tearing up Toronto
him up in and I've got his double-team
him come on he's gonna have his way
there
LeBron fatally over see a coma he's
hotter than fish grease
run coming off the Thompson screen fade
away what'd you expect weeks earlier
this year with a broken hand
LeBron backing down to rosin there's
that fade away and it's butter it's
smooth poor on the shot clock for LeBron
James we're speechless he'll be brown
now LeBron with the rebound and on the
run
Cavaliers spin bucket LeBron and the
Cavaliers with their biggest lead of the
night all-around game you got to wear
this out if they're not called the
double-team they're just milking Kevin
Love bounce pass to LeBron he paid it
back to LeBron
while Sayaka turned his head Ames with
ten points and six assists back to
change nice right down Main Street for
the easy bucket
great pass